je vais continuer d'essayer de
convaincre dans les semaines qui
viennent de l'option que je partage mais
je le répète il n'ya aucune
dramatisation de la situation car de la
conférence nationale du parti communiste
les délégués et conseiller du parti ont
rejeté la proposition de pierre laurent
de soutenir la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon parti communiste supportait
pas qu'ils se mêlent de leurs affaires
donc si je veux faire une des tiges et à
faire ça m'en mêler donc non je ne m'en
mêle pas être milliardaire est immorale
parce que tu une accumulation absolument
disproportionné qui rend fou celui qui a
lui-même milliardaire puisque une fois
que ilham il ya hélas vaudra un deuxième
l'abus n'est pas supportable
le débat qui a eu lieu avant-hier à
tourner pour beaucoup entre une forme de
règlements de comptes ou de mises au
point entre six personnes qui ont tous
été tout était pardon dans le même
exécutif et qu'ils avaient besoin
visiblement de procéder à quelques
ajustements dans le cadre d'un repas de
famille prennent beaucoup taper sur
nicolas sarkozy ce soir
pas taper sur l'un ou sur l'autre j'ai
exprimé les convictions fortes vous
sortez du débat vous êtes souriant
pourquoi olic je pleure en plus que la
sarkozie ils essayent désespérément
d'exciter le les plus dures de ses
soutiens et donc tout ça c'est tactique
électorale et pas à la hauteur de la
situation
on m'a dit que je ressemblais à des gens
mais à qui
comment s'appelle l'acteur de pretty
woman hat en charge ces vins préférés
non pas du tout vous me prenez pour un
neuneu mon tour imaginez pas que je
regarde la télé pour me voir dans un
miroir
juppé lui a reçu un soutien symbolique
ce week end en déplacement en corrèze il
a rencontré la fille de jacques chirac
claude chirac lorsque alain juppé a
exprimé la décision qui a été la sienne
d'être candidat il a été peut-être pas
le premier mais à des tout premiers à
s'en réjouir et est à dire combien il
était heureux pour pour alain juppé est
pour la france un format photo
d'identité alors certains vont trouver
vintage d'autres ont dit qu'elle était
austère quel message vous allez vous
avez voulu envoyer aux électeurs
j'espère que l'élection ne va pas se
jouer serait d'afficher françois
hollande a déclaré un jour que j'étais
une tombe
c'est vrai je suis une tombe et monsieur
le tabac contourne et une tombes dont
l'état vie voilà il faut dix ans entre
le temps d'une décision publique et le
temps de sa réalisation
mais c'est toujours à 10 ans que nous
devons réfléchir dans l'est il faut
aider qu'il faut dix ans pour réussir
je dirais simplement que cinq ans
suffisent pour échouer au prix parfois
j'ai envie de tout envoyer bouler et
quand on me dit là pour la 25e fois à
est ce que vous allez fendre l'armure
vous faites chier avec votre armure
parce qu'il ya longtemps que les fondus
dans tous les sens armure